danke schön dass sie dabei sind herzlich
willkommen zur halle deutschland am
montag einen wochenstart den wir uns
sicher alle ganz anders vorgestellt
haben
wenn nun aber voll und ganz von der
groner pandemie geprägt ist deshalb
starten wir die sendung heute direkt mit
einem kroner kompakt und da sprechen wir
gleich auch mit allgemeinmediziner
professor thomas kurscheid vorher die
neuesten entwicklungen an diesem montag
seit montagmorgen um 8 uhr kontrolliert
die bundespolizei die deutschen grenzen
zu frankreich luxemburg dänemark
österreich und der schweiz reisende ohne
triftigen grund dürfen nicht mehr
einreisen
ausgenommen sind berufspendler und der
warenverkehr
die ständigen gemacht sonst können sie
sich gesund keinerlei beschwerden
warum dürfen in bayern gilt ab sofort
der katastrophenfall
das heißt alle freizeiteinrichtungen
werden geschlossen
restaurants und kantinen dürfen nur bis
15 uhr geöffnet bleiben die
öffnungszeiten für supermärkte apotheken
und drogerien werden verlängert auch in
hamburg entscheidet der senat die klubs
bleiben geschlossen das ende der großen
freiheit auf der reeperbahn
muss ich ließen das nicht zu denken die
ganze straße leer alle norddeutschen
küstenländer haben am montagmorgen
begonnen ihre inseln für touristen zu
sperren
nur anwohner und berufstätige dürfen
dorthin fahren
die sperre gilt für unbestimmte zeit
feriengäste sollen umgehend den heimweg
antreten nicht nur auf den inseln
tausende urlauber die im ausland
festsitzen sollen nun nach hause geholt
werden in speziell gecharterten
maschinen so schade dass der urlaub
vorbei ist aber die haben uns darüber
bescheid gegeben dass aufgrund der
profit 19 situation dass abgebrochen
wird und dass eigentlich alles super
gelaufen dass hopkins institut meldet
heute 6672 infizierte und 14 tote in
deutschland
lars schaade vom robert koch institut
warnt heute erneut dringend davor die
situation auf die leichte schulter zu
nehmen ich sage das deshalb weil es
inzwischen offenbar bereits sogenannte
korona partys gibt wenn die klubs
geschlossen wurden
bitte tun sie das nicht solche corona
partys würden die ohnehin schon ernste
lage nur noch verschlimmern
ja und das können es uns jetzt professor
thomas kurscheid zugeschaltet facharzt
für allgemeinmedizin der kurstadt sie
haben es auch gerade gehört party trotz
krone allein das ist ja schon bedenklich
genug aber teilweise wohl auch um sich
absichtlich anzustecken um es so hinter
sich zu haben ist das eine gute idee was
sagen sie heute ja also also wenn dann
sollten wir jetzt alle konsequent sein
es bringt ja nix wenn wir die kneipen
lehrräume und das jetzt alles auf die
private ebene verlagern also das bringt
überhaupt nichts oder erst recht
natürlich nicht wenn die leute sich
jetzt treffen um wirklich als ich noch
anzustecken das unterläuft alle
maßnahmen der eindämmung der mehr als
kontraproduktiv auch danke dass sie das
immer so ausdrücklich und so stark sagen
ich hoffe sie hören uns gut wir sprechen
uns gleich nämlich noch mal wieder dann
geht es darum zuschauerfragen sehr gut
wir machen eine kurze pause sie können
sich sammeln und dann haben wir ihre
fragen liebe zuschauer die sie ja auch
schon stellen konnten an unseren
experten thomas kurscheid aber jetzt
gucken wir erst noch einmal nach berlin
nicht nur die hauptstadt von deutschland
sondern auch die partyhauptstadt pasta
zudem corona partys doch die macht jetzt
erstmal zwangspause denn seit dem
wochenende müssen sämtliche bars clubs
und auch kneipen der stadt dicht machen
die ansteckungsgefahr auf engstem raum
die ist einfach zu hoch und deshalb
bleiben tausende türen jetzt zu auf den
ersten blick wirkt heute alles wie immer
nicht wirklich weniger leute draußen als
sonst vor der touristen attraktion
nummer eins fällt der unterschied
allerdings doch ins auge
statt den üblichen reisegruppen verirren
sich nur wenige besucher das öffentliche
leben wird immer weiter zurückgefahren
die meisten zeigen verständnis nicht in
dem alter wo wir jetzt so davon
betroffen sind dass wir jetzt angst
haben müssen aber ja klar wir haben ja
auch familie und ältere menschen um uns
herum da muss natürlich rücksicht nehmen
also ich kenne berlin ich war schon
öfters in berlin
und normalerweise ist hier immer trubel
viel los und alles ist voll und ja es
hat schon was anderes jetzt momentan
stark betroffen der kultursektor alle
einrichtungen auf der museumsinsel
geschlossen
nicht alle ausländischen touristen haben
das offenbar mitbekommen
das ist das erste mal dass wir hier sind
einmal immerhin die sonne scheint wir
sind aus südafrika haben 23 schulkinder
dabei wir hatten eine führung gebucht
jetzt ist alles zu
das ist schon enttäuschend berlin ist
wie ein offenes museum man kann vieles
auch von draußen
allerdings fallen auch open air
veranstaltungen aus zum beispiel der
beliebte flohmarkt am mauerpark wo sie
sonst tausende übers gelände schieben
gähnende leere offen bleibt der
zoologische garten für viele eine
willkommene abwechslung mal auf andere
gedanken kommen
entspannt also straßen sind leer
passt alles mein geliebtes auch einfach
nur noch also man hat wirklich angst
dass es wirklich zu kommen mal wird
eingesperrt und was soll mit den kindern
dann noch machen kalt erwischt werden
samstagabend gaststätten gegen 18 uhr
verfügt die politik ab sofort für
restaurants einen tisch abstand von ein
meter fünfzig am morgen danach versucht
man in einem berliner ausflugslokal die
vorgaben umzusetzen
doch nicht alles scheint geklärt steffen
kirchner besitzt auch einen großen
biergarten die abstands vorgabe hier
womöglich ein problem die gäste bedienen
sich aber selber an den ständen bei uns
so dass sie in der schlange teilweise
stehen und wir da nicht sicherstellen
können dass die abstände eingehalten
werden
für max taubert die situation eindeutig
bars und kneipen müssen ab sofort
schließen seit samstag fragt er sich was
passiert mit seinen neuen beschäftigten
die hälfte davon fest angestellt diese
hälfte muss die miete zahlen muss leben
hat weiterhin ausgaben und für mich
stellt sich jetzt in den nächsten tagen
die frage wie kann ich möglichst
natürlich auch die gehälter sichern
berlins nacht und freizeitleben geprägt
von verschlossenen türen bis ende april
vorerst doch nicht überall wird trübsal
geblasen cafés und blumenläden versuchen
bereits aus der korona not eine tugend
zu machen
aber das gehört dazu
ja und um die schnelle ausbreitung des
virus zu verbreiten zu verhindern ist er
heute noch eine weitere maßnahme in
kraft getreten das nämlich sämtliche
schulen und kitas geschlossen bleiben
in den meisten bundesländern bereits
heute schon der rest folgt dann in den
nächsten tagen und damit verbunden
natürlich die millionenfache eltern
frage quer durchs land
wir betreuen wir jetzt die kinder
für die kleinen sind es corona ferien
für ihre eltern ist es ein balance-akt
letzter schultag in baden württemberg
regina becker hat noch zwei ältere
kinder die bereits unter quarantäne
stehen jetzt sind alle zu hause ich habe
sie im clip ich hab's unter kontrolle
ich kann schauen wie läuft es wär es
krank wäre es nicht krank und ich ganz
ein bisschen bisschen besser händeln die
kinder notdürftig betreuen nebenbei
arbeiten und noch die großeltern
versorgen das ist jetzt alltag für
eltern in deutschland
regina beckers partner arbeitet in einer
anderen stadt sie ist jetzt auf sich
allein gestellt die großeltern in die
betreuung einbinden kommt nicht in frage
die lebensmittel bleiben vor der tür es
gilt jetzt sicherheitsabstand zu wahren
ich habe dir essen mitgebracht für den
papa auch gut auch gut bildet ganz
zufrieden
also ich will nicht daran schuld sein
wenn man eltern jetzt sterben würden
oder sie ins krankenhaus müssten ebenso
virus sich dann ein schlepper deswegen
sogar zu hause und das war's dann
zuhause langweilt sich tochter maya
während sohn paul über vector rechnung
brütet sein klassenlehrer hatte sich mit
corona infiziert seit einer woche ist
das gymnasium schon dicht jetzt nicht so
ein lehrer außerdem immer fragen kann
oder auch ich glaube meine eltern meine
eltern können jetzt auch nicht so gut
weil das ist schon ein sehr
kompliziertes thema und deswegen für das
ein bisschen blöd für mich jetzt den
ganzen stoff als qualitäts prüferin kein
regina becker erstmal im home office
arbeiten die frage ist nur wie lange du
weißt nicht was kommt du weißt nicht ob
im herbst die sache zu ende ist weißt
nicht ob es im juli zu ende ist du
kannst nicht planen
das ist furchtbar
dazu noch die sorge vor ersten symptomen
es ist die ungewissheit auf allen ebenen
die auf den familien lastet ja nicht nur
da mehr als 6.600 bestätigte corona
fälle gibt es laut john hopkins institut
inzwischen in deutschland die zahlen
sind also weiter stark gestiegen und
werden dabei auch immer sehr genau
beziffert aber woran erkennt man
eigentlich ob es wirklich der korona
virus ist oder nicht vielleicht doch
eine grippe oder eine erkältung welche
beschwerden sind typisch für eine
ansteckung mit dem neuartigen virus
martin scherer er ist präsident der
deutschen gesellschaft für
allgemeinmedizin und erklärt welche
anzeichen er für eine grippe eine
erkältung oder einer corona infektion
sprechen symptom 1 häufiges niesen
schnupfen ist das ein typisches
anzeichen für coop 19 oder spricht es
eher dagegen was sagt unser experte für
erkältung ist der typisch dass man niest
und schnupfen hat und das sind jetzt
keine typischen symptome für die neue
corona erkrankung
es ist ein mögliches symptom bei krone
aber eher ein seltenes hohe
körpertemperatur fieber spricht das
automatisch für eine ansteckung mit dem
neuartigen corona virus jedenfalls nicht
für eine erkältung sagt der mediziner
fieber werden typisches symptom für
krippe zusammen mit einer plötzlichen
abgeschlagenheit sind dem menschen
wirklich sehr plötzlich auch außer
gefecht gesetzt bei corona war es ein
relativ häufiges symptom
es gibt auch corona verläufe ohne fieber
kratzen im hals reizhusten zu dieser
jahreszeit bei einer erkältung nichts
ungewöhnliches wenn sich zum husten aber
ein zweiter symptom gesellt dann obacht
zeigt unser experte
husten ist eins der häufigen symptome
und was auch bei manchen patienten da
noch dazukommt ist eine gewisse
kurzatmigkeit und diese kombination mit
husten und kurzatmigkeit ist schon etwas
was einen in diesen zeiten eher an
corona denken lässt gliederschmerzen ein
typisches anzeichen für eine grippe doch
sprechen die auch für eine corona
infektion was sagt der mediziner
also kita schmerzen sind ein völlig
unspezifisches symptom für infekte aller
art gliederschmerzen können bei corona
auftreten ist aber kein corona typische
symptom die symptome übersicht zeigt zu
unterscheiden zwischen einer erkältung
einer grippe und einer corona infektion
ist laut unserem experten nicht ganz
einfach
es gibt leider leider keine trennlinie
zwischen corona grippe und erkältung
allein anhand der symptomatik man muss
die symptome bei corona immer zusammen
sehen mit der frage gab es eine
reisetätigkeit im risikogebiet gab es
einen kontakt zu einem bestätigten
corona fall und ansonsten allein anhand
der symptomatik kann man es nicht genau
sagen da braucht man im test dazu
doch welche anlaufstellen gibt es dafür
wo kann man sich auf eine corona
infektion testen lassen wir versuchen
natürlich immer noch eine gewisse
soziale distanz zu halten
das heißt die menschen zu hause zu
lassen und deshalb sollten menschen mit
verdacht auf corona jetzt nicht
unbedingt dann herum fahren herum laufen
die einzelnen 6117 wählen ich weiß die
nummern sind zur zeit überlastet auch
die nummern der gesundheitsämter aber 11
6 11 7 und gesundheitsämter während im
augenblick erst mal die ersten
telefonischen anlaufstelle
experten raten telefonisch kontakt zu
suchen und für einen test keinesfalls in
kliniken oder arztpraxen zu gehen zu
diesem thema das uns alle bewegt und
beherrscht in diesen tagen das spreche
ich jetzt mit professor thomas kurscheid
allgemeinmediziner und auch
gesundheitswissenschaftler aus köln wir
haben uns eben jetzt schon mal kurz
gehört oder zumindest halbwegs gut
gehört
wir denken sie eigentlich herscheid über
ihre eigene gesundheit gerade nach auch
über eine ansteckung immerhin kommen sie
ja direkt in kontakt mit corona
infizierten in der tat versuchen wir das
hier zu vermeiden wir haben also ein
großes schild vor der praxis stehen das
eben leute mit diesen symptomen die wir
gerade gehört haben trockener husten
fieber bitte nicht in unserer praxis
kommen sondern wenn sie das haben er
sich an die uni klinik wenden weil
ansonsten wenn wir kontakt mit einem
solchen patienten haben sogar vor allen
dingen ungeschützten dann kann das eben
zur praxis schließung führen oder
zumindest dass die mitarbeiter erst mal
14 tage nach hause gehen müssten was
ungefähr dem gleichen gleichkommt also
bestens gerüstet auch jetzt für die
fragen unserer zuschauer kurscheid
deswegen sprechen wir auch mit ihnen
da sind einige bei uns angekommen und
sie beantworten die für uns und für
unsere zuschauer zb www sie fragt wie
lange hält die krankheit an
und wie viele menschen sind schon wieder
gesund auch das natürlich ein thema
ja sie hält tatsächlich ähnlich an
diesen grippaler effekt wie schnupfen
heiserkeit zwei bis drei wochen für köln
kann ich sagen dass offensichtlich schon
sieben wieder gesund sind von den
insgesamt jetzt 300 erkrankt man muss
aber ganz klar sagen die mehrzahl
nämlich hier von fünf haben ja fast
keine symptome oder ganz leicht die
symptome nur einer von diesen fünf
kranke etwas schwerer haben sie da
übrigens einen tipp wie man das dann
raus findet wenn diese vielen leichten
symptome man kann das ja gar nicht
richtig zuordnen
man kann es nicht richtig zuordnen im
zweifel also wir werden es ja eben
gehört wenn man aus einer risikogruppe
kommt oder aus einem risikogebiet kommen
muss man es natürlich testen lassen vor
allen dingen auch deswegen um
auszuschließen dass man eben unbewusst
vielleicht auch noch andere ansteckt
denn manchmal merkt man erkrankungen gar
nicht nur als beispiel
wir haben ungefähr 100 verschiedene
erkrankungen die wir jeden tag durch
machen ohne dass wir es merken und dabei
kann unter anderem auch ein cabrio ist
maria finish will wissen wenn man das
virus hatte kann man sich neue
identifizieren infizieren natürlich
infizieren ja man kann sich sehr
wahrscheinlich nicht neu infizieren bei
allem was wir jetzt wissen es kann
natürlich sein dass die antikörper die
man bildet und die gedächtniszellen
irgendwann nach zehn jahren nur noch so
wenige sind dass wir uns vielleicht ein
zweites mal anstecken wenn das können
wir jetzt noch nicht sagen weil es die
krankheit einfach noch nicht so lange
gibt ist denn die hoffnung auf den
frühling etwas hilft das eventuell schon
der frühling gegen korona fragte wo
böden kann man dazu schon was sagen
trotz dieser neuigkeit der krankheit der
frühling hilft insofern als dass wir uns
nicht mehr viel in geschlossenen
gebäuden und räumen aufhalten und
rausgehen draußen ist die
ansteckungsgefahr um ein vielfaches
niedriger wenn nicht sogar 0
hinzu kommen die höheren temperaturen
okay da mag man sagen ja im iran gibt es
ja auch irgendwie infizierte ja aber es
gäbe sehr wahrscheinlich mehr im iran
bei heißen temperaturen wenn sie jetzt
doch kalte temperaturen hätten und wenn
alle leute wirklich drinnen sich
aufhalten ich sage danke herr professor
kurscheid für die beantwortung unserer
fragen hier im corona kompakt ja und
unserer kroner kompakt das finden sie
täglich neu auf youtube und dort auf dem
kanal der zdf heute da können sie dann
auch weiter ihre fragen stellen
und es gilt ja weiterhin und in diesen
tagen natürlich umso mehr an diesen
herausfordernden alle informationen zum
corona virus finden sie jederzeit online
auf heute.de und auch heute abend noch
mal in einem zdf spezial um halb acht
hier im zdf